If you're looking for a reason to divorce your husband,
I got you. Stanford did a research study on children
published in the journal of neuroscience,
where they did MRIs in children's brain
and saw what parts of the brain were stimulated
when they listen to their moms voices
versus when they listen to novel voices.
Meaning, like,
friends or strangers are just other new people in their life.
And right around the age of 13
is when children's brains kind of stop
getting the same sort of reward
from hearing their mom's voices.
And now everyone's voices is just as rewarding.
So mom is now in a sea of voices.
So as a mother, when you stay for the kids
and you are just kind of gonna trudge it through life
so that you can make it to their adulthood,
and that's when you'll start to build relationships with them.
You were naturally given those first 12 to 13 years of life
that it was kind of just you guys.
They were young, very dependent on you,
and you had all the opportunity in the world
to be the mom that you need to be
and to speak into their life the way that you wanted to,
and to, like,
teach them the lessons and give them all the things that you wanted to.
That's why sometimes
we look back on our children's childhood and feel so much regret,
because we realize how precious and tender those moments were.
So I would just challenge you to think about,
do you really wanna give up those years
being in a miserable marriage,
knowing that one day
your voice is just gonna be another in a sea of voices?